that means can can you
hear me uh can you hear us can you hear
us
can you hear us where's the chat so we
can make sure if they can hear us or not
there's okay is this it right here yes
that's a good start hello more like
we've never gone live this early before
i know
i know we're usually like way later hey
tm
mma king we are
here there we go
oh my gosh people are coming in right
now
um this is great this is great i'm
always happy to be here
we will watch our language i'm going to
stare at the last one
major demonetization thanks buddy
appreciate super saiyan i got a nice
beard i do like our beard
someone mma king knew rockstars that's
right our episode just premiered
did i know it was coming out this time
otherwise i wouldn't have announced the
live stream coming out this time it has
to not overlap with that one the whole
point of this live stream is to tell you
to go watch that video
yeah go watch our new rockstars video
click off and come back in
an hour nissa oliva in the chat
all right guys well today's theme is
gonna be a fun one uh it's gonna be all
the movies and shows we've watched
during quarantine so far
we'll be naming ours off randomly
throughout the stream
and then of course be reading what you
guys have also watched as well
so keep going into the comments and keep
listing whatever
it is that you guys have uh
been watching during this quarantine
time
uh alrighty so i'll kick it off with my
first one and then of course yeah we'll
go to the chats and everything
but let me actually let me see really
quick who else do we got thanks anisa
oh alan ramsay over here saying watch
placed me on the pines again recently
such a good movie
i'm curious do you think that the uh
also by the way
i never say this but i feel like it's
important to say it
can you guys hit the like button i don't
even say that in like
non-live stream videos but can you guys
hit that like button i feel like it
makes a major difference yes
i don't really know how it makes a
difference but i notice everyone else
keeps saying it and i think that
it does help the algorithm so yeah
upvote the live stream more people will
show and then we'll get to 200
concurrent viewers and then i can reveal
the surprise
is that how it works that's how i've
chosen to make it work but i might
change it oh awesome that's good to hear
if we never get to 200k
well uh yeah i mean if you guys can go
ahead and hit the like button that mean
a lot thank you for everyone who has
done so already
um oh i'll kick it off with the one that
i've seen uh recent
recently and john and i were planning on
it was not really a plan but it was kind
of like an idea
that just didn't really pan out which
was uh maybe streaming extraction but
due to time with patreon and stuff it
just wasn't able to make it
work um but i watched extraction
recently
have you seen it yet no not um it's a
pretty badass movie
yeah like it's it's really badass
i don't really care for the storyline in
between the action scenes
there's this one really popular sequence
that happened in the movie that is
basically like it's supposed to look
like one take it's
it's obviously not one take but it goes
on for such a long time
and it's still really impressive and and
absolutely beautiful to look at
and chris evans uh that's the right one
right no hemsworth
because hemsworth is just always alive
to watch come on
and even though i didn't really care for
the script in between i still thought
that it was
uh i still thought it was a really cool
movie and i thought the acting was still
great and the way it
shot is cool it's kind of got like
something michael bay lighting but it's
shot better than a lot of michael bay
movies
uh yeah i would i would definitely say
uh extraction
john you got one oh man i rece i've
watched
actually probably more movies in
quarantine than i've watched
in a long long time yeah like what um
we revisited uh both bill and ted movies
which made me so happy partly because
it's been a while since i've seen them
both and this was the first time that we
were all able to come together and agree
that even though excellent adventure you
know sets the standard bogus journey is
pretty awesome too so
yeah i love that movie and that actually
has uh perhaps my favorite on-screen
grim reaper i love what william sadler
does in that role and i'm so glad he's
coming back for part three
um so yeah yeah that's a piece of
escapism we got into
good call john thank you i'm proud of
you thank you gregory
we've watched i i got movies for days on
this one let's see what some people in
the chat are saying right here chester12
we have watched cobra kai
we did uh first season together and then
i did season two on patreon uh
season two on patreon uh we got jacob
who binge watched battlestar galactica
series twice have you seen battlestar
galactica i've seen that none of
battlestar galactica and let's talk
about battlestar galactica on this live
stream i feel like it makes for some
really good material didn't katie
sackoff be on that show
yeah yeah she's in the mandalorian
cedric watched dawn of the dead and
that's a good call right there
hey speaking of zack snyder just last
night we were watching 300
and uh the dvd of 300 must be cursed
because we had two copies and both of
them broke
two of our dvd players oh
we got uh let's see here melanie uh
melanie watches uh watch the crow that
was one of my childhood movies growing
up that's a great movie they should
remake it
with timothy chalamet that that's
what everyone wants you know i don't
want it but i think it could work
person uh shouts out to andrew gordon
because person was watching daredevil
2015
and the punisher from later so if
anybody
can share that uh daredevil love it's
andrew gordon oh we got some super chats
in here let's
let's acknowledge the super chats yes
let's get super
all right oh so our first one thank you
ryan beatty
that's one of his names uh he says hey
guys the original jurassic park
treasure planet lion king 94 a lot of
disney and i'm binge watching doctor who
at the moment
of course you're binge watching doctor
who at the moment uh he watches with us
on our patreon as well
um those are changing very slowly those
are some great movies to watch right now
jurassic park
absolute classic i've never seen
treasure planet
i i saw as a matter of fact we lost what
can't say
something yeah i almost almost gave a
spoiler and almost got an email from
asserted christian harloff about it yeah
careful there it's easy to do that there
was a question
that came up in regards to treasure
planet that's all i'll say
somewhere what round it was in the
showdown but i won't even say it was the
shmo
yeah i appreciate your super chat by the
way yeah it was lion king 94
a lot of disney i love your i love your
taste
it's all disney kids movies treasure
planet
lion king 94 and then you got like
jurassic park here yeah the most
horrifying
film to get into back in the day uh some
people saw that i was i talked about the
sopranos on
i'm sitting here in the chat i talked
about the sopranos on um on stardust and
yeah
i'm on season three right now that's a
heavy ass show
that's that's one of the shows i'm
watching right now and yes
it's one of the original heavy ass shows
i gotta tell you guys
i have been uh continuing the clone wars
i started again
in a chronological order so much better
that way
i'm on the movie right now i'm only
halfway through
the movie because i was like all right i
can easily carve out 22 minutes at least
one to two times a week to watch a clone
wars episode
and of course that's a movie so it's a
little bit of a longer experience uh but
honestly i've heard so much crap about
the movie like the movie sucks but the
show's good
watching the movie uh because it's to to
watch
clone wars in chronological order you
got to watch the first two episodes and
then the movie
and watching the first two episodes
properly first i don't know if i'm
sounding like it makes sense right now
watching the first two episodes first
then going into the movie makes them
i'm honestly really enjoying the movie
so i'm not on this like hate bandwagon
for the film because
i think watching in the proper order
just makes absorbing the storytelling
that much easier to do
well it sounds like you're watching that
at the front of your viewing experience
so you don't have as much build up
in your head i don't remember where the
movie came out in relation but
yeah yeah john got any commentary on the
clone wars oh the clone wars well you
know
uh you know after uh bo katan lost the
dark saber
and uh maybe we should go to our new
rock stars all
literally all of my clone wars thoughts
are in that video
where we had to kind of spoil the show
for ourselves in order
to do a good job on new rock stars
that's
how seriously we take some of these
games
what are some other people in the chat
watching right here daredevil on netflix
michael was saying that
you know fun thought i've been thinking
of trying to possibly contact charlie
cox for an interview
but then i'm like all i've seen from him
is daredevil that would be a boring
interview
the theory of everything yeah so we can
diversify
i mean i'm sure i've seen charlie cox
and other things that aren't coming to
mind but i'd only want to talk to him
about daredevil
and i feel like he'd be so sick and
tired of talking about daredevil
by this point you know just just a
little thought
if you guys are new to the stream we're
talking about movies and shows you
watched during quarantine
and uh if if you've been here for a
little bit make sure to hit that like
button
i think it does something i think it
does um okay who else do we got in the
chat here do i just click this
hey yeah yeah yeah uh no wrong one
yeah there you go hey anissa oliver i
expect nothing less on anisso oliver to
be in the super chat yeah
it wouldn't be one without her criminal
minds tv show
is one i've been watching have you seen
that lines i've seen
a few episodes that's the one i remember
when it came on they were like this is
the crime procedural show
it's gonna get messed up it's gonna be
the really dark gory one
you know john every time something's
brought up of a show you're always like
i've seen some of them
how come how can we never get ever
completely how can we never get a thing
where you're like yeah yeah i've seen
the whole thing it's always i've seen
bits and pieces
i've seen something and then you go on
and talk about stuff as if you really
know what the material is
what is your problem well you know jack
of all trades master of none
including in including my viewing
shooting
storytelling i like to catch disparate
details
with criminal minds i mean i feel like
if you've seen 10 episodes you
understand what the show is
yeah you know they're not gonna they're
they're literally not going to break the
mold every time is it violent
it's pretty violent it's pretty dark
it's the one where it's all about like
uh
i think the focus of that crime
procedural is like
mental disturbances and like serial
killer type stuff specifically
oh and of course i've been watching
hannibal as of late here's how this
stream is going i've noticed so far i'm
gonna review our stream every five to
ten minutes
we we're we're giving our stuff and then
we're looking at the stream stuff and
then we're going with the super chat
stuff
and everyone keep going
nancy justified is a show i have been
dying to start because i love tim at the
all of fun and i've heard that show is
great
rewatched sorry for cutting you off
what was this show that you've been
hearing about that or you've seen bits
and pieces of
or seen fragments i just said it was
justified
justify with with timothy oliphant yeah
he's great
yeah um whoa john we're not going in the
order i'm so sorry
you said the order what was the order
i've lost i lost track of the order so
far okay all right
super chat was number three all right
let's go back to okay super chat is next
on the list here
uh rizzo gaming thanks again buddy
and back to the futures are all comfort
movies and shows for me
beyond that i'm just getting
recommendations and working my way
through them
and they're all on netflix all the back
to the futures are they really
i think so yeah last night we were
looking for 300
and i found all of those movies and
stuff so uh in regards to ryan beatty's
super chat thank you again ryan
what would you say your favorite back to
the future movie is john
you know when i was a kid i would have
definitely said part two just because
hoverboards
and like cool future stuff um
i feel like now it would either be one
or three
but uh that's just way to make your
answers exciting uh
i would i don't know why this is my
go-to bit
your the first like 20 minutes of every
livestream is
just make fun of john until yeah until
you got something else to talk about
craig
back to the future too is definitely the
one i have the best recollection
of but uh but yes i i would think
that the first one's probably the best
one but there's something oddly charming
about the western
uh i i would say it's back to the future
one for me still it would go one three
two for me for back to the future but
that's the future are great comfort
movies man yeah i think there's always
something to appreciate about it
upon every rewatch and this is not um
necessarily a movie or a show it's
definitely not but i want to shout this
one out
i saw chris stuckman's uh i don't know
how to pronounce it
i've seen so many of them i still don't
pronounce it hello
i think it's hilarious hilariosity his
catwoman hilariosity review
and that was fun oh and i've also seen
uh john campio's
uh rant about rubber patterns
in the face of his fans i mean i love
john campia i really he's a friend of
mine
well i really do and you love about him
and i love how passionate john campbell
is
because even though i don't agree with
what he was saying i i he's just so
entertaining to watch he set out to make
the espn
of movie news and i think he's done that
and it really showcases in that rant
right there
um i i remember he uh the last time i
saw him it was after his rant about the
jack hine guy
on collider and i told him like one day
i want to go on your show and i want you
to say all those exact things to me
yeah that's gonna be my like fan tribute
thing i want
just rip me a new one john tell me how
much you disapprove
all right let's see what other people
have been saying here in the
in the stream all the robocop movies
from holographic
movies rick and morty the upside down
good boys godzilla
and favorite thing watching us
buddy we are not better than robocop too
come on man we're at least on par with
part three though
i love ben arkham's cardman ben arkham
is saying play batman
that's very aptly named username i will
do that
ooh neomh is this your first time
watching the haunting of hill house
oh if it is that's a treat that is the
weirdest binge watching
show i've ever seen and binge watching
is not a word but it's the weirdest
binge watch show because it's so
deliberate and so
like way more of a drama than it is a
horror show
yeah yet you just want to keep watching
the [ __ ] thing
it's that good you do it like it's it's
not like it's high on suspensers got the
craziest [ __ ] cliffhangers in the
world
but yet you want to keep watching the
show i
i really think um uh uh
um oh my god give me the first letter of
that director's name okay
okay m i know it's like mike something
mike what's the first letter of his last
name
f mike mike furmantron
mike
mike flanagan uh he's going to be he's
directing a new stephen king movie hey
that's all he wants to do jj abrams gets
all the star
stuff and then he gets all the stephen
king stuff
jordan peel have all the lovecraft yeah
if you guys are new here
movies and shows you watched during
quarantine make sure to hit that like
button
man that's annoying to say make sure to
hit that like button make sure i would
just assume that if you liked the video
you'd hit the like button but you know
apparently that's the thing we haven't
been doing all these years telling
people hit the like button
well and honestly since we've put more
focus on it i as a youtube user have
started using it
way yeah me too nowadays i interact with
videos so much more
very true john you have a redemption at
your bernie sanders impression
it's time for bernie alvarado's
ooh i love your super chat dude
you're super jet
i love what you contributed here just
say it say it john do your bernie
sanders impression for bernie alvarado
i watched jurassic park and my hero
academia
which character from my hero academia is
your favorite
and what is your favorite quote from the
show um
oh my god john that was a great bernie
sanders impression thanks man i
i just relaxed into it now just to make
sure we're not isolating everyone can
you re-read
um bernie alvarado's super chat thank
you again by the way
but in your best donald trump voice i
watch jurassic park
and my hero academia which character for
my hero academia
is your favorite and which is your
favorite quirk from the show
it's got the best quirks best characters
i don't know ask anyone
who likes his anime they'll say it's the
best i don't know
uh if you're if you haven't seen my hero
academia not people whoever's in this
live stream
but it is seriously one of the best
shows ever um
my favorite okay my my favorite
character and quirk from the show my
hero academia do you have an answer
i like the guy who thrust his crutch
who's that guy there's that
sky crotch guy yeah i am a yeah
yeah yeah yeah laser guy
he's my favorite yeah who made midoriya
the cheese plate i just don't see his
power ever truly coming in handy
like a real battle and um how is he so
high up at ua academy
i really have a soft spot in my heart
for izawa for every reason i just love
how like
over everything he constantly is but in
terms of quirks i love dark shadow uh uh
tokuyami's uh like bird guy
i think that's pretty rad well thank you
bernie alvarado thank you burn
wait oh mma king saying wayne's world i
still you know i haven't seen wayne's
role but
i listen to conan o'brien needs a friend
podcast
no mike myers oh this is why you don't
interrupt
you always try to sound like a
know-it-all and then you just mess it up
clearly i didn't know it all do i try to
sound like a know-it-all
maybe it depends on the time
atlanta john loves that uh
at some point it'll come back anthony in
the chat is saying jack ryan the witcher
which is the new jack ryan series how do
we jazz this up for the kids
jack ryan was in the witcher yeah
toss a coin to your john grisham
character
i'm gonna watch your key i want to watch
akira sometime in the next couple weeks
that's the question that's coming up in
this chat right now i feel like that is
one i i owe it to myself to watch
all right let's see where oh log you
biff tannen all right
um okay let's see here pj
thank you pj appreciate it buddy um
i have been watching a ton of survivor
five seasons in the past
week haha rewatched all marvel movies as
well
you're being efficient how long have we
been under quarantine how many days
damn dude how have you i i don't know
how you room you managed
okay so pj appreciate the super chat
buddy but are you
also um completely not working at all
at the same time because i don't know
how else you'd have the time to watch
the survivors a long show survivor's a
long show and
the mcu is a loss too i'm like you've
got you've got what 23 movies
plus you've got uh 24 episodes a season
for five seasons that's over a hundred
that's 200 episodes of survivor
or no wait i'm doing the math it's over
100 episodes yeah
we've only been under quarantine for
like 45 to 50 days right yeah so yeah
i feel like you're doubling up for sure
you know what i've noticed about this
live stream
on this chat what there is not one
similarity here there's like maybe
marvel movies this
might be the only thing i'm seeing here
that's consistent
but everyone in this live stream all are
like
they're all over the place but
everyone's been watching i love that
robert becerra
is here uh to keep mr magorium alive in
these chats
i've heard killing eve is really great
and i'm super happy that cedric
you watched creep one and two i've
actually not seen creep two yet but uh i
love the first creep
so would you guys say like uh would you
guys say that right now what you're
doing during quarantine
is you're uh re-watching stuff
or are you catching up on stuff are you
more looking for for like your
your comfort shows and comfort movies
i'm seeing some people here who are
saying like
i've rewatched all of the office um but
then i'm hearing movies i'm like is this
a movie you're watching for the first
time like alien resurrection
yeah no but silence
seriously like if you can name name if
it was a first time or a repeat because
i'm also trying like i've watched i
think
i know i've watched three movies i
haven't seen before
in this time and i've rewatched a lot of
things i haven't seen in
ages so uh i would love to know
can i just say no i'm just going to slow
down the process of getting to the
questions and everything
but i really i really do love doing the
live streams
i really do yeah man they're so much for
fun i i i never know if they're actually
good
if i'd be totally honest yeah i've said
that to some people who i've talked to
on patreon i'm like
i honestly have no idea if they're good
um i
i just know that it's this is like the
most you'll get
of you know like when we're when we're
shooting like a real video like an
actual video where
i'm also thinking about like the editing
and i'm thinking about all these things
and time and
exporting and import like there's so
much on my mind about oh we got a big
to-do list we usually have like 20
things on our whiteboard that we got to
knock off
and uh with the live streams it's just a
it really had i would say like with
quarantine with this top of being
quarantined this has probably been like
the greatest thing in the world of just
it's it's made me feel more comfortable
um to be
even more of myself yeah in in life
and and and on camera too you know not
really
concerned so i appreciate anyone who's
here right now
this is our first time doing a live
stream at this hour during quarantine
time so appreciate everyone who's here
well yeah and i feel like
in doing these too it's a nice outlet
and i think it's a nice way to
uh i'll like there's something to be
said i think for having
a show that is very loose to kind of
reset the week
you know so it's like we can get on here
we can have fun interact with you guys
you know chill out a little bit in a way
that's still entertaining so yeah thank
you all for
for feeding this yeah for making it what
it is seriously guys thank you because
this is the first time we've ever had a
consistent live
like we've done one-offs here and there
before but yeah this is our no they've
been it's a whole blast
the meg the meg great choice
uh tm you're so nice you're so crazy
uh sweet life on disney plus is another
one i'm hearing a lot of
proto sprouse hillary b been watching
reactors good to know
who's your favorite though hillary b
yeah rank them
um let's see here this is
so interesting to see what people are
are actually watching right now
anissa how oh my god anissa look
thank you also hello to my two lovely
people how is your day going i feel as
though you don't get asked that question
enough well i i wish i read your super
chat before
saying how much i love doing the live
streams because that would have been the
perfect opportunity to
segue dude into being a little sweet and
a little sentimental towards what we're
doing right now
yeah you really wrecked the show now
because you always catch us in a
slightly different mood
with every every stream that we do
and it's weird because normally when we
go on a stream there's been a lot of
random tense things that have been going
on and then
we go on a live stream and then it like
hey we're having a great time and then
we just
go into this bubble of loosening up and
it's been
like really it's actually been there's
been some hiccups along the way
uh this week but overall it's been a a a
positive week
and um i'd say i'm doing i'm saying
we're
i'm good i speak for both of us i'm
we're doing good
if you're good i'm good yeah you know
yeah
uh i feel like we this week had the
luxury not
it's not not always a luxury at the time
but i feel like this week was very front
loaded
so usually we're doing these also at the
end of a
it's like the last order of the week
yeah or you know perhaps a long day
perhaps long week
so i feel like yeah too this week has
been the front end was we got to get
this brand deal for gpk up we can
you know do this other thing for uh new
rock stars and now it's it's it's
chiller
also um another movie i watched
i watched this movie for the first time
randomly put it on
nicolas cage movie it's called moonlight
have you seen that moonlight yeah john
have you seen bits and pieces not
moonlight
struck i was about to say i i have seen
all of movies
several times chrissy brings me tonight
bring me the big night
yeah what'd you think was it a big fan
that's fair
review over
i like it but i you know i didn't get it
i didn't i think i laughed maybe one
time way late into the movie
okay i couldn't tell if i was watching
some weird dark
dramedy or a comedy it just was and then
by the end of i was like okay so i guess
the takeaway is
cheat and you'll find love that was
my experience with moonstruck okay okay
return to it in in eight years time and
just see if it's grown
because i yeah i mean you gotta be
around like 40 years old to really
appreciate the movie moonstruck
i'm just transcribing my own experience
of watching it as a child and being like
i know that one scene where he says the
big knife thing and then growing up and
then being like
oh i i appreciate this now
uh but yeah there that's actually an
interesting topic there
at least has been one or two movies i've
seen where i'm like you know
i might appreciate this much later in
life which one
uh there's a movie called possession
comes directly to mind it's an 80s
uh like domestic horror movie with sam
neil
and every a lot of people i know are
like this thing's a masterpiece
i love it it speaks to me and i saw it
in the theater and i was so aggravate
like i was aggravated it's one of the
few movies where i was like
please stop stop with this jarring style
um but yeah i just don't think i was in
the right place to appreciate it
john i listened to most of what you said
repeat it all you verbatim
oh we got tara erickson in our chat
ericsson everybody go subscribe to tara
follow her on stardust go be on our
patreon everything
all the above uh if you guys haven't
don't know tara erickson i'd be very
surprised if you don't but tara erickson
i want you to know it's it's a wild
experience with her every single time we
do a live
a a video together because she's
actually a fairly calm human being in
real life
you have a magic mojo that you can just
flip on
we talk with each other before we film
every single time because we're actually
friends so
we talk with each other usually
sometimes we go way too long for talking
before we finally get to filming
and and we'll just be having like a real
conversation
not even really many we don't even
really joke around and then suddenly
that camera turns on i'm in a relaxed
mode i'm like all right we have a good
relaxed rapport
and then she's just like falls to the
wall insane
i'm reenacting a trailer i need to
readjust
as soon as possible with tara's energy
i'm gonna
start my own side channel where i just
do parodies of terror
i know but tara's the best man is the
best tara's good people
gosh i have not seen the hateful eight
extended edition but good for you for
watching it
re-watching the raid movies that's a
good call man
all two of them what's open here
hbo we should upgrade our camera well we
should upgrade we should get a rain off
a [ __ ] yeah
let's spend 16 000 we'll rent it out to
films who need it to pay it off and then
in a few years we'll be able to use it
i'm not gonna justif but we we we
currently edit on two
two computers and our other computer is
[ __ ] almost dead like it just it's
from 2012 it's holding on and we just
spent a lot of money to get a new
computer a lot of money
so that way we can keep things going
smoothly again
and then we'll work on the camera
afterwards right now the camera is
pretty good for the actual videos
yeah well and yeah keep in mind that
this is a live
you know capture card port so exactly
it's gonna be a little less than normal
quality
oh my god brendan v joined the chat nice
to see you here buddy
who's getting into more horror movies i
think i saw him saying that's nice to
hear that's good if you need
recommendations
throw him out there whoa whoa whoa wait
a minute
brittany lang i'm seeing here your
message was retracted
wow did you swear were you saying some
why was your message retracted yeah what
gives well
how could you i just want to say those
are the best kind of super chats
where you don't even have to answer it
and you just go thank you
come again yeah i'm just joking for
changing your profile photo
britney if you super chat i mean i
appreciate yes she did change your
profile
good notice thank you it's called
empowerment you got to learn how to do
it
if you want to be successful yeah what's
in line with you guys
i'm empowering john right there that's
called a compliment i feel powerful
now he's going to do a better job not
just here but
in life because i gave him a compliment
empowerment all it takes is the one john
don't
you don't have to talk sometimes all
right i'm sorry sir and that's called
constructive criticism
can i offer you a piece of advice you
don't need to talk
but brittany if you have a question let
us know yes
yes feel free to throw it in the free
chat and we'll try and rather
anissa back in the chat would expect
nothing less thank you anissa
so sweet riverdale
ah supernatural oh what happens on
supernatural season 12 rolling on season
five spoil the show for us
does sam and dean make it trying to
catch up for the series
don't worry about any of that edward
edward she
recently saw the recent saw ed wood
thanks to you
john lost my pearlies in the war dude
john look at you your recommendations
are being received i know
how does that make you feel it feels
good because i rarely recommend
directly to people there are a few
movies where i'm like
you would like this but to be fair i
think she asked me what my favorite
movie was
it seems like a lot of people someone
here is watching scream three a lot
it seems like more people are watching
shows than movies now
i'm glad to see somebody's watching king
kong 1975
because uh jeff bridges doesn't get
enough love for that
limitless somebody uh just somebody was
today talking to me about limitless
that's a good story yeah about that's
called
i said no but i remember the trailer and
it looked good and i heard it was good
you haven't seen limitless not even the
tv show where bradley cooper shows up
not even the tv show
not even the tv everyone's seen the
limitless show
oh i want to see that documentary i
thought
uh bill alex winter made side by side
not keanu reeves i thought it was a bill
not ted
you know what i watched oh my god god
john please let me interrupt you
this is important this is a damn good
comedy
i watch the movie good boys that's been
recommended for a while
that movie i like more than super bad i
really love that
oh oh oh apparently judd apatow's
watching the stream right now and
doesn't want the camera working
uh that movie it's at least he's
learning how to edit it's easy to
compare it to super bad
but what was great about it was they
actually felt like they
i think they might be very surprised if
they're not
i think they cast like real little kids
and
there is so much heart in that movie
and the compliments you would give it
would sound like you're
the same compliments you would give
super bad yeah um but i watched it by
myself and i can only imagine how funny
how great of a time it would have been
in the actual
feeders with a crowd but watching it by
myself i i don't laugh as much at things
out loud
consistently when i'm by myself but that
film had me cracking up
if you have not seen good boys i think
you can watch it on i think i watch on
hbo
now um so yeah i i really think
that is a worthwhile movie john what are
you doing on our stream
i am trying to wreck it ralph
oh john you said you watched like a
gazillion things what else have you
watched
i am gonna shout out alex hein really
quick for watching loving vincent
because i'm also going to use that as a
segue but that is a very i'd be curious
to hear your thoughts just because it's
not like
super typical in terms of story
structure but it's really beautiful to
look at and on the heels of that
i watched two animated movies i had
never seen before
and what were those john one was kubo
and the two strings
uh which is a leica joint and i mean it
was absolutely gorgeous to behold and i
i really like the way that they
go about marrying their different kinds
of animation and um
yeah just has a ton of aura it was
really beautiful and it told like a
samurai
type tale a samurai action type tale um
you know in the animated format so i
thought that was a cool transposition
too
i'm on stardust to see what john's not
mentioning and i also watched an
animated film called the secret of kells
which is an irish production i believe
which is um it's about a real book
called the book of kells which was uh
you know religious text that these monks
were you know pouring over and working
on
uh and it's hard to describe but
basically it's
it's about you know this uh village
that's trying to fortify itself when the
vikings are about to attack it
and uh you know this young boy is really
engrossed in working on the book and all
that and
it's got this really beautiful aura tone
like it's an animated movie that a kid
could watch but it's not
aimed directly at kids so it has this
really beautiful baroque
classical art style it's it's not
a tradition like it's not the viewing
experience you're used to with an
animated movie but it also has
all the personality and imagination that
you're used to so uh yeah i would
definitely recommend that especially if
you want something that has historical
roots
and mythological roots is this is this
kind of review
the thing that's going to get you to
your 200 viewers you're looking to get
yourself that's exactly it i'm mostly
trying to
please golden hd by making the channel
as fun as it used to be
by going off on a
brief review of an animated film i
watched wow what they're doing in the
soup
in the live stream then i love the mean
people who join the live stream do you
love the mean people because i can dish
it but i can't take it
no i can't either in fact i'm crying
there's just the tears are flowing down
my throat
um wait a minute wait okay someone's
watching gotham hey someone watched
blood
uh bloodshot so much how was bloodshot
yeah shouts out to them that actually
worth it shouts out to them they sent us
copies of the book actually i was
thumbing through them
yeah let me say did you read it or did
you just yeah peek it
or sneak it yeah you read the whole
thing
oh wow bloodshot you completed something
hey that's that's a fair rib me
completing things is
a feat alex underwood happy birthday to
you
wrinkle the clown is that the horror
movie all right so we got uh
oh that guy carrie look at this person's
thumbnail right here
watch ages of shield and supernatural
with the awesome gents oh thanks for
being a patriarch
dude finish phase two and through the
mcu because i felt uncultured whoa this
is your first time watching it
is it actually you're having an
interesting viewing experience
dude he finished phase two and through
the mcu because he felt uncultured so
he's finally catching up on the mcu
finally seen the end game and now he
just finished game of thrones these are
like the two
biggest things from last year yeah game
of thrones and an
endgame and so he's catching up on the
two biggest things in pop culture right
now
so now i'm thinking by finish do you
mean like you
hadn't seen all the way through part two
like phase two so you picked up or did
you
have like pieces of like had you seen
infinity war and end game
up until that point or was all that new
to you too because like
watching so much like a half a decade's
worth that's so close together had to
have been interesting
and now he's finished oh dude how great
is that final season of game of thrones
how great how great is that fun i mean
we've had a lot of finales
in 2019 rise of skywalker
game of thrones end game
so great let's face it game of thrones
did it
number one and best one ryze skywalker
was second best
an end game you know it doesn't really
belong in the same way
i don't i just don't think it yeah i i
don't want to put that movie together
totally unsatisfying really unearned
crossovers why did everyone leave the
livestream what just happened
me me m catching up on classic albums
speaking of
actually i just i i was bumping at
queben i just recently because i don't
have a
great uh knowledge of the outcast
catalog so i'm i've been educating
myself and uh that's some groovy
groovy shiz joanne just finished from
what i'm sorry say someone's like i just
remembered
hey did you not get spoiled i hope not
hillary i gotta check your your patreon
message how did you like
stranger things for the first time i've
seen a lot of love for the show called
center
stage here in the chat i don't know what
that is
well i'm sure maybe you've seen bits and
pieces of it but then we'll talk about
it as if you've actually seen it
yes we shall at a later date
hey if you guys are new to the stream or
if you've been here for just a few
minutes make sure to hit that like
button i want to see if that does
anything
hey i heard i saw some love for hacksaw
ridge there
you boy mel oh my god oh my god oh my
god
my god my god mel oh my god
mel gibson did the right thing because
after the whole jewish
rant the boggle after the whole jewish
thing he he
cast a jew in hacksaw ridge his next
his follow-up directing movie
post post-jew rant
you know what he cast a jew the only way
he should go on
even further apology and and just make
like a holocaust movie starring a woman
he wanted to make a movie i think about
the maccabees but
um apparently the jewish community had a
problem with it
can't see why no that's why i mean the
guy behind lethal weapon
is that what it was i don't think it had
anything to do with the ramp the best
way for him to redeem himself
is to literally run somebody else's
culture through his own filter
the wire you know i wanted to watch the
wire first
according to the live stream we have
zero viewers on here
wow nobody cares wow nobody cares about
but we have
actually we have excellent connection
though but zero viewers
we have 111 likes
according to what we can see it says
zero people watch
it went from 111 to no one's watching
you right now
no one cares move on
and i know it's just a glitch in the
system
but i'm still taking it personal as if
it's something that's really happening
to me right now oh it is really
happening well considering that youtube
is malfunctioning on our end
let's go through some of the super chats
then while we're here shall we write a
comment if you're still here um
i think people are but we can't we can't
see them because uh
something's going wrong with youtube
greetings to switzerland
all right let's see here brittany lang
oh brittany lang actually got a question
now thank you brittany
see earlier if you guys are just tuning
in but apparently no one's tuning in
last time on the live stream uh brittany
lang submitted a super chat but there's
nothing there and now she's got a
question
hey guys how's it going the shows that i
have been watching is
friends and re-watching the witcher and
on disney plus
the mighty duck saga is the mighty duck
saga like the cartoon one
yeah wow or or just all the movies we
talking all the movies
uh i guess we could call that a saga if
you learned to call it a saga
re-watch well if you're re-watching the
witcher already it must be
that good of a show because anytime i
re-watch a show especially
i wait a while before i re-watch the
show are you checking to see if we're
still live or you're just checking text
messages
uh oh do we got to redo this i don't
know oh no
yeah let me check the youtube itself oh
no
this is bad this is so bad
but it says we got 73 viewers here maybe
it's reconnecting i don't know
oh anisa just hit me up what's happening
my youtube app is loading nothing
oh no oh we shouldn't edit this out we
should leave all
we should leave all this no one's even
here right now
oh my goodness
oh okay
oh oh boy how do we reconnect what do we
do we should leave all
we should leave all this in yes people
should know had the awkwardness behind
[Music]
this
we're ending this livestream